this is a production of Cornell
University so the title of my sort of
overview takia saw health pioneers in
emerging frontiers I've already
introduced myself there's more about my
bio in the the handout you've got so I
will without further ado proceed on
what's been exciting to me as someone
who's been working on this at Cornell
since about 20 years ago is when Cornell
first started working in the area of
soil health and he is it's just a great
merging of an era in the science and
particularly soil biology and soil
ecology of major discoveries with our
old petri dish techniques we really
hardly knew what was going on with terms
of microbial community in that soil
though with molecular biology learning
much more just amazing diversity and
abundance and learning that almost all
of those things are very beneficial for
farming and learning how to manipulate
them and some of those I talked about in
my book that came out about 15 years ago
called tales from the underground but
what this blended with was at the same
time that we were having these amazing
discoveries about learning more about
the life underground the farmers were
becoming worldwide and in new york in
particular farmers becoming aware that
while we've had continued productivity
even in increased productivity over the
past century in a lot of cases this is
coming at the expense of our soils
gradually degrading particularly losing
organic matter so a lot of farmer
motivation to do something to rebuild
our Dannic matter make their souls more
productive more resilient and this also
blended with also new information we
never had before about the biology and
then we're we're learning today about
soil health human health in the
environment all those links that farmer
aspect was really captured in book by my
colleague Harold Vanessa can't be here
today
building stories souls for better crops
kind of really a how-to for farmers may
the farmers been very familiar with this
and cooperative extensions been through
numerous additions Harold wrote that
with Fred McGraw from University of
Vermont they finally we have our most
recent book here I've got on the list
the one we're gonna hear about this
afternoon from David Montgomery at
University of Washington growing a
revolution and in that book he's there's
a lot of things but one thing that I
like he's that I'm very
why we wanted him today for this talk
really does a great job of capturing the
the history the worldwide movement
happening and farming and how we really
are on the cusp of a major revolution in
in farming and puts it in that
perspective
so that's fascinating stuff one of the
things that we know today that we had no
idea about when I was in grad school to
the age myself but it really wasn't that
long ago when I went to grad school that
was plants and what their roots do is
take up water and nutrients for the
plants and inker the plant in the soil
we know now that what's probably as
equally an important thing of what
plants do is what their roots exude into
the soil they reduce they release a fair
amount of the sugars from photosynthesis
which attracts bacteria to them it helps
them those bacteria can help them mine
the soil around them for nutrients they
exude trace amounts of chemicals that
inhibit weeds insects and disease
attract all kinds of beneficial microbes
to them and also can release substances
that literally dissolve nutrients in the
soil the other ones couldn't acquire and
the other thing that we really
appreciate more is how roots towards
their way through the soil and
particularly with compacted soils some
of them are able to do this help break
up compaction in a more natural way
instead of tillage and also this creates
pathways water oxygen for other roots
perhaps cash crops to follow and of
course they're all sequestering these
roots are sequestering carbon deep in
the profile which otherwise would be in
the air is the greenhouse gas carbon
dioxide so without going to a lot of
details about all this kind of research
a lot of this is going into our thinking
about rotation crops today and fall
winter cover crops learning not just the
amount of biomass they produce which of
course is important getting organic
matter back into the soil crucial to
soil health but these other things they
might do for particular problems
one example is Sudan grass which will be
familiar to many of you our farmers are
working with farmers in the room the
Sudan grass is now known to release a
compound called sergo Lyon which can
suppress weeds and also pathogenic
nematodes so if you got that kind of
problem this is a good prescriptive
rotation crop but you've got compacted
soils this is a good one to try it's its
roots are very capable of getting into
compacted soils now of course also it's
pumping organic matter deep into the
soil and as I say that these these
plants and these substances are
releasing are not only important in
their own lifecycle but can be very
valuable to a subsequent crop to follow
so that's this plant legacy of that but
all of this work is going into what's
happening with cover crop research today
another big thing about cover crops and
this is where really farmers I think
take the lead and often eat us as much
as we leave them Forrester
is um how to you know so even if we
accept and understand that for example
using all winter crops in the ground
covered increases they have all kind of
benefits trying to integrate that into
our cash cropping systems and a short
growing season is very difficult and so
many farmers are really leading the way
and this is showing a picture of some
interceding of a corn crop these
techniques for really integrating this
into our cropping system so a lot of
exciting stuff going on today and we'll
hear more about that today so I talked
about new stuff new discoveries about
what roots do and of course then there's
the whole thing all this soil biota and
all these things we're learning about
them so in addition to roots possibly
some species releasing substances that
control weeds pests and disease certain
microbes can help us in that way
basically biological control underground
that top picture a cute little picture
of the mouth part of an immature a
little microscopic worm that's under
than many different species in this well
a couple of them are parasitic to plants
but hundreds of these species are in
almost any handful of soil and many of
them beneficial this is a bacterial
feeder the mouth part of a bacterial
finger these microbes of course are very
important in nitrogen cycling and
essential to all life on the planet
actually played an important role in
making all kinds of essential nutrients
for plants and for humans actually
available so they play important roles
and that the nitrogen fixation that
something many people are familiar with
legume crops would I have a picture
there below the that memo toad is
showing some tiny Rhizobium bacteria
nitrogen-fixing bacteria are latching on
to the soybean root a root hair of a
soybean plant leg implant those will
invade the root welcomed by the plants
because they will capture nitrogen from
the air spaces in the soil in exchange
for forests and baits and we're
more about how to maximize these sorts
of symbiosis all of these creatures that
are in the soil and the large abundance
of them release sticky substances and of
course the fungi that are in the soil
released those five high feed that
helped hold the soil together and this
leads to good soil aggregation which is
amazingly just critical to water holding
capacity and good drainage and swell if
there's no if there's the soil is
completely dead and you'll have very
poor soil aggregation without a doubt
and also the roots themselves some of
the substances they release help hold
cells together so that's another crucial
thing for grabbing flooding resistance
so this is all new information working
into our research this is slide from
Matanikau kniffen a researcher at
cornell so biologists who unfortunately
had a family emergency and couldn't be
here today but this is where she lives
in the rhizosphere very narrow zone soil
just within millimeters of all the plant
roots if you pull up a plant there's
that soil it sticks to the roots that's
really the rhizosphere just that really
narrow it's a hot spot a plant subtle
interactions involving microbiota and
again most of them are microbiota that
we're called for that send out signals
to attract those microbiota to benefit
them and so we're learning a lot about
controlling that rhizosphere making the
most of it um
Jenny's research really works a lot on
okay so microbial community we know
we've known for a long time that many
farmers of course always been concerned
about disease organisms might have
negative effects but how do we how do we
maximize those those big guys in the
soil that might have these positive
impacts on our plant and now and
suppress are the pathogens and those
others and so a lot of work on compost
and various ways to manipulate soil for
that purpose
I mentioned pioneers I wanted to mention
you know at least one or two going quite
a ways
this is dr. Sahlman Westman who is a
professor at Rutgers University one of
the first kind of true a University
accredited you might say cell biologists
working in the 1920s and 30s he had
grown up on a farm and he was convinced
having grown up from he saw so many
diseased plants and animals turned into
the soil and somehow this the soil
doesn't just he continued becoming more
and more toxic he was convinced there
had to be he coined the term antibiotics
and they helped purify the soil and at
the time he was working penicillin had
been discovered but that was the only
antibiotic we really had take a long
story short after years of research he
does he discovered streptomycin and got
the Nobel Prize for medicine in 1952
I've coming much more to the present
time another kind of something that
happened just about 15-20 years ago is a
lot of talk about soil health emerging
around the country around the world and
here at Cornell but this thing of what
it's kind of a wishy-washy phrase what
is that and what Cornell really has been
at the forefront of one of the things
Bennett is really developing a new kind
of soil test for the 21st century that
goes beyond just the chemistry of soils
which is what our parents and
grandparents knew about pH acidity then
calcium and magnesium and nutrients in
the soil but also integrating into the
soil test biological and physical
indicators and I don't have time to go
into a lot of detail about Cornell's
comprehensive assessment it's all Health
Program but we have a table in the back
right here and that's got some
information about this and the website
there for those of you interested
there's a lot of of course groups
working on this it's a work in progress
we're always updating this and improving
okay I wanna talk a little bit about
chillage now because I talked about one
way of rebuilding our soils building the
organic matter is this idea of
maintaining vegetative cover so
basically as much of the year as
possible sucking co2 out of the
atmosphere and some of that ends up in
the soil as organic matter it's a pretty
good thing um but what happens with when
we plow and till the soil is that over
oxygenates the soil and it really
accelerates microbial activity that's in
the business of breaking down organic
matter there's nothing wrong with
microbes doing that but if they do it
way too fast it's so called we fans the
flames excessive organic matter
decomposition and those nutrients
disappear before plants can even acquire
them and at least out of the soil this
often on this problem of too much
tillage often begins with a problem of
compaction obviously i've compacted soil
a farmer thinks I've got to go out there
and kill it and plow it so you get on
this vicious circle of um compaction
they need to increase tillage that then
leads to declining organic matter
because oxygenating the soil less
organic matter less food for the soul
food web he were so microbes there now
that reduces soil aggregation poor soil
drainage in the summer from vicious
cycle so the way to get away from this
is it still may need some chilies for
very severe cases of course we're also
integrating into this the idea of using
cover crops to be illogically with their
roots help break up the compaction we're
actually thinking about things such as
on performance and and the worth work
they can do helping break these things
um speaking of pioneers seems like as a
biologist I no matter what I'd get into
chose Darwin was there before me so he
was I saw a biologist to his last book
for those of you don't know so we may
know about this was a 200 page book on
earthworms the important role they
played before this many of them were
many people just of his parasitic
creatures but quote from him when I was
one of the most ancient and most
valuable of man's inventions but long
before he existed the land was in fact
very cloudy and still continuously
plowed by earth worms
last they just wanted me someone other
kind of technique for um rebuilding
ourselves is directly adding organic
compost or manure and our stuffing is
actually more about pure carbon
substance can be fortified in various
ways or attract microbes to it and be
benefit to the soil and so we'll hear a
little bit more about that I'm sure
today as well so it's never a venue
reducing tillage crops directly adding a
soil amendments I have just a few slides
left um I wanted to talk about what's
really exciting also and we had a
meeting just before this this morning
talking about all these win-win aspects
of soil but something that farmers are
motivated to do strictly from the bottom
line maintaining productivity of their
sorrows in improving their climate
change resilience resilience to extreme
weather events particularly droughts and
flooding and erosion the reasons I
mentioned aggregate stability etcetera
but also it's what we call a natural
geoengineering solution for carbon
capture
so all that organic matter we store in
the soil that's carbon that's usually
sixty percent or so of carbon that's
carbon uh where would that be otherwise
in the in the air is the greenhouse gas
carbon dioxide so that's why there's
this interest in this linking of a civil
health and climate change
finally just a couple more slides um
what I wanted to emphasize is that you
know we are not in New York here way in
the back of the back of the line about
soil health we have really been at the
forefront farmers and researchers and
our agencies like dairy markets for
conservation also USDA NRCS
working with us we've been at this for
more than twenty years this is a full
picture I pulled the slide that's George
always some of you may know him he was a
plant before he's recently retired plant
pathologist at Cornell really helped
form our first soil health program work
team along with myself then now Harold
and Esther Cornell and but this really
we were responding to you see those
growers there we respond to their
interest I don't know I I don't know if
Daddy brands in that picture might be
there one about door panel and I think
part of that first team but we want to
focus on today is season we move towards
the end of the day is yes we've done
these great things we're gonna hear some
of the cool things everybody's doing
working on but where do we go from here
how do we really why isn't everybody
adopting these things that we still are
a long way from full adoption and
maximizing and fully benefiting
ourselves so we need to move forward
we'll talk more about that during the
day so finally just specifically about
our project New York so health here's
kind of what our near-term objectives
that we're working on um identifying
barriers to adoption we're using soil
surveys farmer surveys etc other ways of
looking at that one a funny economic an
environmental benefits one thing a lot
of farmers ask that are interested in
this is yes I see and I hear about these
benefits but how long will it take for
me to see those benefits is it going to
be two years five years 20 years because
we'll see in one of our presentations
later this afternoon it depends on which
benefit you're talking um so it does
vary and it's going to get better
information about that innovative
cropping systems and so ecology research
we'll hear about that from a number of
our speakers today and some of them been
funded through our project research on I
would check on compost another thing I
know area of research were funding and
this are very relevant to what's
happening today and very big part New
York so like I said it's everybody it's
not a criminal thing
and it's really promoting stay when a
communication coordination and
collaboration one of our major goals is
almost accomplished and there's several
hours that we'll really accomplished
hold the first statewide still has some
we hope it's the first of others to
follow and also something we'll hope to
accomplish beginning it's an input from
you later today I'm gathering input from
the full range of stakeholders for on
New York's future we already many of you
are involved in that already I will get
input for more of you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu